what about your the worlds that you
create they're so intricate both of you
in different ways
you're both known for creating these
richly detailed worlds I'm wondering if
you do research or what your process is
for creating those worlds is it
something that requires reading or even
sketching maps or something of that
nature or do you just dig into the story
and start there and I'm interested in
hearing from both of you how you write
well I think ever since folk poping
fantasy does require a map and fantasy
fans expect them I expect them to I like
maps
I even like real world maps and all that
but I certainly like fantasy maps at the
front of my fantasy books have been set
in the secondary world Damon Knight once
famously said that he would never read a
book with a map in the front so Damon
was wrong about a number of things but
as well as being a defender of Clarion
and write about things well Damon was
like Chairman Mao right 51% of the time
it's a you win particularly with epic
fantasy which of course is what a swarm
of Ice and Fire is the the setting is
very important those of you who are in
creative writing courses literary
courses will know about the elements of
fiction and you know you'll have
teachers probably back in high school to
talk to you about character and plot and
theme and all of the different elements
that go into the short story and setting
is usually in that list but it's it's
usually way down on the list it doesn't
get a lot of attention because if you're
writing about the real world or the
mundane world that's a science fiction
writer would say it's the world that's
all around us you don't have to describe
what an office looks in a detail people
know where an office looks or a living
room or so forth or they know what you
know what you'll find in New York City
or farm in Kansas but if you're really
dealing with totally made-up places you
know we wouldn't know what the shire
looks like except opium tells us what
the shire looks like and draw us a map
and you see the relations of the place
to each other
you learn a little about history and how
long it's been in place and that gives
that gives a verisimilitude to it that
is uh equal to a mainstream writer just
saying I was born on a farm in Kansas
you can't you can't do that without
doing some world building in fantasy or
science fiction to some extent Tolkien's
first breakthrough in America was in the
late 1960s he wrote water rings in the
50s but it was published only in
hardcover and on in England very few
copies made it across this the ocean
until a spook discovered that there was
a lapse in the copyright laws so they
pirated it and put out a unauthorized
paperback edition which actually forced
okyun to license it to Ballantine Books
which put out the authorized Edition and
they became enormously popular
particularly with young people college
students of the 60s and a lot of people
I knew had had a poster on their wall a
token poster but it it's interesting me
coming back
what was that poster was it a portrait
of Gandalf was it you know Frodo and Sam
walking somewhere was it Aragorn with a
sword no none of those things it was a
map of middle-earth that was the poster
that sold millions of copies to the to
the students for the 60s middle-earth
was a character in that book
middle-earth the setting was as vivid as
important as everything else and there's
been a Tolkien calendar now which has
been going on for half a century every
year there's a new poke in calendar
something that I'm trying to imitate
with my Westeros sites and Frederick
calendars which been coming out for like
10 years now but you look at the Tolkien
calendar and even without reading any
legends you know these places you just
have to look at the art to do that the
painters that the artists are creating
okay that's Rivendell that's ministerís
that's the Shire oh here's one where
they're in the mines of moria totally
made-up places well we know what they
look like we see an image and then we
instantly recognize them just as we see
recognized images of Paris or Angkor Wat
or
you know any of the places that exist in
the real world that Taj Mahal toking
created his world with such detail that
his fantasy places took on a tangible
life in our imaginations and live there
still and I think all of the great
fantasy books do that Narnia
we know what Narni is like Oz rummy
Howard's Hyborian age and hopefully my
own Westeros these places have been
built in such detail that there is real
to millions of readers as Thailand or
Mexico or you know Berlin and that's
perfect as far as I'm concerned that's
that's very cool and it's I think it is
necessary a very strong sense of place
and setting for fantasy books it has
proof or transferred to a certain extent
particularly since in science fiction
one of them subgenres that I love the
most is the planetary romance where you
go to another planet and then the joy of
it is the same but different and like
Earth but not like her how is it
different and it needs to be specific
and also if you're doing a novel and a
science fiction novel so it isn't set on
earth in the present you have what I
call the cardboard sets problem from
Star Trek the cardboard sets that you
what you would want to do is compensate
for that by a little bit of a hyper
realism where you add more detail and to
make sure that you believe in this
setting and it isn't the cardboard set
behind some kind of an adventure and
then in terms of my own longest novel
there have been stories about Mars for
forever as humans have always been aware
of Mars and telling stories about it but
they were always just a made-up space
until 1976
to a certain extent 1969 but the Mariner
passed by during a dust storm so it was
1976 when Mars was handed to us on a
platter
so the Percival Lowell he got it wrong
HG Wells
laws bits of Bogdanov all of the great
Martian literature after Percival Lowell
said he saw canals it was although kind
of made-up Mars same with Ray Bradbury
with Martian Chronicles it might as well
have been Arizona same with you know
Edgar Rice Burroughs as Mars is his
Percival Lowell's Mars done over and
over again but they never had the place
and then in 76 then you did have maps
it's precisely in the sense of satellite
maps in great detail and lo and behold
the place was like but not like it was
like New Mexico on steroids everything
was a hundred times bigger than the
earthly feature that was similar to it
so that the biggest volcano on Mars
would turned out to be a hundred times
bigger than Mauna Kea and the biggest
canal was a hundred times longer than
the Grand Canyon
it went and on and on like that there's
a noctis labyrinth us is a set of
labyrinth like you'd have in a fantasy
novel Olympus Mons would stick right up
out of the sky so as you climbed the
mountain you'd climb out of the
atmosphere there's a canyon at what I
called the Dover gate where you'd be
looking down a depth that would be four
or five times deeper than the Grand
Canyon at its deepest spot and it's real
and that's the thing that I found
interesting real but empty as as
spectacular as anything a fantasy
novelist could make up but the next
planet out so that had to be a character
and nobody had the opportunity to do
that until 76 and there is indeed a
bunch of Mars literature in the 1980s
but I decided to throw caution to the
winds and you know double down on making
the landscape of character to just a
really beautiful thing